apaisant relaxant le domaine de marly le
roi fait penser à un petit versailles
avec son canal ses statuts et ses
grandes allées morts beaucoup plus calme
[Musique]
où
méconnu du grand public ce dernier reste
souvent dans l'ombre de son voisin le
célèbre château de versailles pourtant
il vient d'être labellisé jardin
remarquable par le ministère de la
culture une reconnaissance qui a demandé
au personnel en charge du dossier
beaucoup de travail pour remplir les
critères demandés pour la manière de
présenter le site le jardin également
sur le patrimoine architectural s'il ya
des collections de la statuaire s'il ya
du patrimoine environnemental également
de naturel
c'est un point majeur qui a été mis en
valeur au sein des dossiers et qui a
beaucoup plu également au groupe de
travail qui a labellisé le site le
challenge est important puisque en fait
j'ai une double vocation ici non
seulement la conservation d'un site et
d'un patrimoine culturel avec ce jardin
historique mais aussi c'est de
réinventer une forme de jardins forme
elle est régulière et de le réinventer
dans un usage moderne et de mettre en
valeur la naturalité du site en tête
[Musique]
avec ses 53 hectares classé monument
historique et ses 44 hectares gérés par
l'office national des forêts le domaine
de marly le roi rassemble les amoureux
de la nature il ya une étude faune flore
qu'elle vient d'être
déjanté par le pv sur une année entière
et donc on a des résultats qui nous
prouve qu'on est sur un site tout à fait
exceptionnel en région parisienne pas
tant que ça et les amoureux d'histoire
c'est un domaine de villégiature qui a
été créée par louis xiv de manière
quasiment contemporaine à celui de
versailles il faut savoir que le domaine
de marly a été construit en une
vingtaine d'années petite vingtaine
d'années ce qui est exceptionnel quand
on connaît le faste qu'il a connu
donc c'était vraiment une demeure
secondaire voire tertiaire de louis xiv
ouvert à l'année le domaine de marly le
roi est aujourd'hui un lieu de fête de
visites et de promenade où les touristes
les sportifs et les familles cohabitent
dans le calme